حضر رئيس مجموعه رئيس نيجيريا هولا احمد
تيليبو من ان رفضه قاده انقلاب النيجر
النيجر التجاوب مع مقترحات المجموعه سيفتح
الباب لتحرك ما سماها اطرافا خارجه عن
سيطره اكواس للتدخل في النيجر ويتزمل هذا
مع وضع قاده الانقلاب الجيش في حاله تاهب
القصوى غداه مطالبته للسفير الفرنسي
بالمغادره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الرساله التي
يبعثها وضع قاده الانقلاب الجيش في حاله
تاهب وعلى اي نحو تقرا باريس تصعيدهم
تجاهها بطرد سفيرها في النيجر وما هي
الجهات الاخرى التي تحذر اكواسم تدخلها
المحتمل في النيجر من دون اذن المجموعه
وما واجهه المبررات التي تسوقها اكواس
لتفسير اصرارها على انهاء الانقلاب وما هي
طبعا خيارات فرنسا للتعامل مع تصيد قاده
الانقلاب ضدها وعلى اي نحو سيتفاعل الغرب
مع هذا التصعيد وكيف سيؤثر كل ذلك على
مسار الاوضاع في النيجر
[موسيقى]
اذن بحسب مراسل الجزيره فان قياده اركان
الجيش في النيجر امرت بوضع القوات المسلحه
في حاله تاهب قصوى تصعد عسكري ياتي غداه
سياسيا وجه ضد فرنسا التي قالت وزاره
خارجيه النيجر انها طالبت سفيرها بمغادره
البلاد بسبب رفضه دعوه لمقابله المجلس
العسكري وبسبب تصرفات صدرت من باريس
وتتعارض هذه التصرفات مع مصالح النيجر
بحسب وصف الوزاره وفي توضيح لمعلومات نقلت
عنها سابقا اوضحت وزاره خارجيه النيجر
انها لم تطلب من سفراء الولايات المتحده
والمانيا ونيجيريا مغادره البلاد
من جانبها رده الخارجيه الفرنسيه على
اجراءات ميامي بقولها ان الانقلابيين في
النيجر لا يملكون سلطه تسمح لهم بطلب
مغادره السفير الفرنسي
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع وينضم الينا من
ينام يا دكتور علي يعقوب الاكاديمي
والمحلل السياسي ومن مدينه
جنوب
غربي فرنسا
رئيس المعهد الاوروبي
لدراسات
الامن والاستشراف ومن واشنطن ينضم الينا
شون ماتفيت الضابط السابق في قوات النخبه
الامريكيه اهلا وسهلا بكم جميعا ارحب بكم
في هذه الحلقه ودعوني ابدا من النيجر من
يامي والدكتور علي يعقوب نريد ان نفهم
دكتور علي يعقوب اولا
ما سبب كل هذا التصعيد العسكري من طرف
قاده الانقلاب والرساله لمن بالضبط
ربما لا تسمعني جيدا دكتور علي لكن سؤالي
كان عن اسباب التصعيد من طرف قياده
التصعيد العسكري من طرف سلطه الانقلاب
والرساله لمن برايك
على كل بالنسبه
لقاده الانقلاب
ليس هناك تسعير في
قضيتهم وعندما يحاولون ان يدافعوا
انفسهم
فمثلا او يثبتوا انفسهم على كل حال فلما
كتبوا لسفير الفرنسي خطاب لاسماء في وزاره
الخارجيه فرفض ان يحضر
فاسروا القرار الذي سميناه البارحه ومازال
نتحدث عن تصعيد السياسي لكن اتحدث عن
تصعيد العسكري وحاله التاهب التي وضع فيها
الجيش
بالنسبه
لحاله التاهب القصوى للجيش
فيه معلومات وصلتهم البارحه كما سكان
عاصمه النيجر كلهم يعرفون انهم يتوقعونه
هجوم من من
[موسيقى]
ذلك اظن استعدوا وايضا قد يكون هناك ما
يسمى بوسائل حرب الاعلام والدعايات خاصه
لبادي الاحزاب المعارضه فلذلك استعد
البارحه كانوا بعدهم قالوا ممكن قبل الفجر
سيكون في هجوم على البلاد وشيء من هذا
القبيل وكذلك يتوقعون من فرنسا التي رفضت
سفيرها ان تغادر البلاد ان تهاجم لو شاب
وذهبوا الى السفاره وطلبوا اخراجه او شيء
من هذا القبيل وهذا كله يعني استباقا
للهوادس قبل ان تكون فاستعد العسكري ماذا
عن السياسي وموضوع يعني طرد السفير
الفرنسي في النيجر
[موسيقى]
كالعاده غالبا حكام الجدد اذا جاءوا
يجمعون سفراء فدعوهم امس الجمعه في
الوزاره الخارجيه
فرفض ان يحدوا اصدروا قرارا باخراجه من
البلاد خلال 48 ساعه وحتى في الليل جاءت
بعد
الرسائل
سفير امريكا واين واين ولكن هذه النفيت
بعد ذلك نعم فهذا اخر
منزعجه جدا من تصرفات حكوميه فرنسيه ضد
مصالح النيجر عن اي تصرفات تتحدث
نعم هي الدوله مستقله منذ 1960 فاذا طالبت
بمغادره السفير من السفراء بغض النظر من
يحكم مفروض على الاقل يستجيب لما قالوا
احتراما لرغبه البلاد ولشعب البلاد
[موسيقى]
لن يقل هذه النقطه الى باريس الى
لماذا لم تستجب فرنسا اذا لطلب قياده
الانقلاب بمغادره السفير
يعني فقط السفيره الفرنسيه ولكن عددا ايضا
من السفراء الاخرين الغربيين اذا ليست
فرنسا وحده ولكن هناك ايضا في هذه النقطه
فقط
تم تصحيح هذا الخبر وقيل ان السفير
الفرنسي فقط هو المعني بالموضوع المغادره
تم تصحيح رسميا
يجب ايضا اتاكد منه حتى لو قالوا هذا لا
يعني انه صحيح وانا انظر الى مسانده اخرى
تتحدث عن طلبات الى سفراء اخرى اخرين عفوا
اذا نتحدث هنا عن اراده من السلطات
الجديده للنقاش مع سفير الفرنسي وهذا رفضه
اسافيره وبالتالي فرنسا الان لديها خيار
اما ان تبقي سفيرها
وان تتبع المسار الذي دائما تابعته كما
فعلت في بوركينا فاسو او كان هناك سابقه
ايضا مع احد السفراء في معالي
السفير جميع الذي ايضا تم استدعائه اذا
فرنسا تنطلق من مبدا المفاده
الاستمرار في العمل الدستوري واذا كان
السفير قد قدم اوراق اعتماده امام الرئيس
بازون هو لم يقدمه امام مجلس الحالي
وبالتالي فرنسا تعمل بموجب حقها الدستوري
حاليا يجب فقد دستوري في ماذا
يجب فيه فقط اشير الى انه واشنطن نفت ان
نعمت ان يكون سفيرها قد طلب منه المغادره
من النيجر لكن فقط بالنسبه للنقطه الاخيره
التي ذكرتها باريس قالت ان الانقلابيين لا
سلطه لهم لطرد السفراء او لطرد السفيرسي
فيما استندت الى ذلك الى ماذا استندت
اوراق الاعتماد التي قدمها السفير قدمها
امام الرئيس بازون اذا هو الذي قدم
اعتماده اليه وبالتالي نتحدث هنا عن ما
حصل منذ سنتين ضمن هذا المسار المنطقي
نتحدث عن الحق الدستوري الذي لا يعود
لفرنسا بل للنيجر اي مبدا المبدا الذي
تنطلق منه فرنسا هو انها لا تعترف سوى
بالانتخابات التي حصلت منذ سنتين طيب شلون
مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون
الافريقيه تقوم بجوله في ثمان دول افريقيه
طبعا من ضمنها كيف تتابع واشنطن هذا
التصعيد وهذه التطورات
لديها اسلوب مختلف عن اسلوب طريسي فيما
يتعلق بالتعامل مع النيجر وغرب افريقيا
لديها مهمه كان لديها مهمه في النيجر قبل
اسبوعين واخفقت فيها تقريبا انها طردت من
بلاد بدون ان تقابل الرئيس بعزوم او رئيس
الانقلابيين لكن الولايات المتحده تفضل
الحل الدبلوماسي وليس الحل بالقوه كما
تدعو ذلك
وسبب ان الولايات المتحده العمل بهذه
الطريقه هو الذي جانبين اولهما ان هناك
حوالي الف جندي امريكي في شمال النيجر
يقومون باعمال مكافحه الارهاب ولا يريدون
التضحيه والاطلاع هذه المهمه والثاني هو
ان الولايات المتحده ترى انها لو غادرت
النيجر فذلك سيخلق فراغا تحتل روسيا هو
مجموعه فاجنر كما فعلوا في مالي وبوركينا
فاسو وبالتالي الولايات المتحده اختالت
اسلوبنا وطريقه مختلفه تختلف عن تهديد قبل
ان اذهب الى الدكتور علي يعقوب مره اخرى
لكن هذه نقطه جديده بالنقاش
قال الان انه الاسلوب الفرنسي مختلف تمام
عفوا الاسلوب الامريكي او الطريقه
الامريكيه في معالجه الوضع تختلف تماما عن
الطريقه الفرنسيه وانه امريكا حريصه
واشنطن حريصه على جنودها حوالي الف جندي
في شمال النيجر لا تريد ان تعرضهم للخطر
فرنسا ايضا لها قوات في منطقه الساحل
وقامت ربما اكثر من امريكا كان لديها
عمليات وقامت بعمليه برخان وعمليه سبرايل
في مالي وربما وجودها تقليديا اكبر من
وجود الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ما الذي
يدعو فرنسا للاصرار على هذا النهج
الاستئصالي في التعاطي مع الازمه في
النيجر
دجاج
فالموقف الامريكي والفرنسي متماثيلان كلهم
منهما يدعو الى حل ديبلوماسي تدعوان الى
او تدعون الايكواس الى التدخل من خلال
الوساطه من خلال وجودها وتاثيرها والنيجر
جزء من الايكواس تدعوها اذا او يدعوانها
الى الوساطه
يتوجهاني اذا الى رئيس الاقواس وبالتالي
ليس هناك اي اختلاف في الموقفين الفرنسي
والامريكيين من هذا المنظور الموقفان
يدعوان الى دبلوماسيه ومن ثم نتحدث هنا عن
تفسيركم انتم
لرغبه فرنسا في تدخل العسكري هذا غير صحيح
فرنسا تريد عوده الرئيس بازون في ممارسه
صلاحيات التي صوت له شعب النيجر لكي يقوم
به هذا هو المبدا الدستوري الرئيسي ثانيا
بالنسبه الى الاختلافات بالنسبه الى
الولايات المتحده وحفاظها على الالفئتين
تماما كما فرنسا تريد الحفاظ على 1500
جندي وكذلك ايطاليا تريد الحفاظ على 300
جندي والمانيا ايضا تريد ان تبقى اذا
نافذه في مكافحه الارهاب
من هذا المنطلق ليس هناك اختلاف جادريه
هناك فقط اختلاف طفيفي الاليات اذكركم
بانها سلطات في النيجر قد اعاده النظر في
اتفاقات الدفاع
بالنسبه الى ابريل 2020
كتاريخ اخير لكن يعني استغرب سيد من اين
استنتجت بانه في تقريرنا قلنا بانه فرنسا
تريد التدخل العسكري ربما هذا الكلام يقرا
في كلام رئيس نيجيريا بالعكس لنستمع الى
ما قاله ونتابع ما قاله رئيس نيجيريا بولا
احمد
الفرصه للرد الذي قال الرئيس نيجيريا الذي
تتراس بلاده مجموعه اكواس حذر وفق وسائل
اعلام من ان ما عادا تجاوب قاده الانقلاب
في النيجر مع اكواس بانه سيفتح الباب
لتحرك اطراف اخرى خارجه عن سيطره المجموعه
وطالب المجلس العسكري الذي حمله مسؤوليه
تعريض شعب النيجر للخطر طالب المجلس
العسكري بالتزامات الاستيعاء لاستعاده
النظام الدستوري بالبلاد قبل فوات الاوامر
وكشف رئيس نيجيريا نيبو عن ضغوط قال انه
يتلقاها تتمثل في مكالمات هاتفيه مكثفه
بشان استعداد بعض الدول للتدخل عسكريا
مؤكدا انه مازال يعمل على ثني هذه الاطراف
التي لم يسميها ومجموعه اكواس عن استخدام
القوه
لانهاء الانقلاب في النيجر طبعا رئيس
مفوضيه اكواس الذي تقول المجموعه انه اطلع
مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون
الافريقيه على جهود السعاده الحكم
الديمقراطي في النيجر في مطلع جولتها التي
ستاخذها الى ثمانيه دول افريقيه اوضح لها
اسباب اصرار اكواس على انقلاب في النيجر
من خلال جهودنا الجماعيه في اكواس تمكنت
المنطقه من الاستقرار وتحقيق الديمقراطيه
وسياده القانون لكن قبل فتره شهدت المنطقه
ثلاثه انقلابات عسكريه ويمكنكم ان تفهموا
لماذا نتعامل مع الانقلاب في النيجر بحسم
ودون اي تهاون لانه حان الوقت لانهاء
العدوى
اذا نعود للنقاش ودكتور علي يعقوب فينيابي
رئيس نيجيريا يتحدث عن احتمال تدخل
الاطراف خارجيه خارج مجموعه اكواس يلمح
الى من برايك
بحسب رايك انه ينبه الى فرنسا لان ما في
هناك دوله تحدد النيجر بالتدخل غير غير
فرنسا بل كثير يتهمون عنا فرنسا هي التي
حتى مولت بعد
النفقات التدخل العسكري التي الذي يتزامه
منظمه
فرنسا هي المقصوده بالنسبه لنا هنا على كل
ما في دوله اخرى لان امريكا كما نعرف ليس
مع تداخل العسكري وانما تفضل حوار
الدبلوماسي اذا فرنسا هي المقصوده بهذا
الشيء بلا شك
في باريس
يعني هل ترى هذا التحذير واقعي
لعبه
تصريح رئيس نيجيريا
كثيره ليس لديها القدرات العسكريه للتدخل
العسكري هذا نوع من التفكير الرغبوي كما
يسميه البعض او رغبه او امنيه
فقد اشير الى 12 الف قوى من القوات مستعده
للتدخل من السنغال
وسحل العاج والنشاط اضافه الى تشاد ولكن
كذلك يجب ان يكون لديهم القدره على التحرك
من النقطه الف النقطه ولكن الاليات
العسكريه هي نفسها ما تملكه الولايات
المتحده وفرنسا ودول اوروبيه اذا كان هذا
ما يشار الهيدا نعم الاخوه ستكون بحاجه
الى عدد من القوات الغربيه للتقود هذه
الحمله ولكن ليست فرنسا فرنسا سوف لن تقود
اي حمله اذا لم توافق الولايات المتحده
على ذلك هذا يعني انه حاليا ليس هناك
احتمال قيام الاكواس بعمل عسكري
اذا كنا نتحدث من قبل عن القوه الاقليميه
التي تدخلت في غامبيا في 2017
والسينيغال هو الذي اتخذ مبادره التدخل
بقرار امم يجب ان نعود الى الحرب
حرب الاهليه في جنابيسا
وسيراليون وغيرها لكي نتحدث عن هذه القوات
اذا قوات تنتظر مع تؤمر به ولكن حتى الان
هي لا تشكل اي تهديد فعليا
للسلطه الانقلابيه هذه التدخلات الخارجيه
التي يحذر منها رئيس نيجيريا كيف تنظر لها
واشنطن
اعتقد ان فرنسا ولديها تاريخ طويل في
التدخل في مستعمرات الافريقيه القديمه وهم
مبديا هذه استعمرات استقلت منذ 60 سنه
وفرست تدخلت 50 مره في هذه السنوات
وبالتالي ما يريدونه لانهم يريدون التدخل
لكن ليس
كفرنسا بل يريدون الكون بقياده اكواس ولا
نيجيريا ولانه اكواس بدون نيجيري لا شيء
وقد قالوا بانه سيدعمون عسكريا لو طلبت
ذلك وعلينا ان لا ننسى ان فرنسا
تحصل الكثير من اليوناريوم التي تستخدمهم
من النيجر وهي الثالث اكبر مزوده
والتي تحتاجها فرنسا
لتشغيل الطاقه الكهربائيه في البلاد
وانتاج تاريخ طويل هنا واذا ما حصل غزو
فناليكم بقياده فرنسا سيكون تحت قياده
اكواس
دكتور هناك تاريخ طويل للتدخلات الخارجيه
كما يقول شورناك لكن هناك تاريخ ايضا طويل
للانقلابات وهناك حان الوقت انه بعد وقوع
اربع انقلابات في المنطقه في مالي في
بوركينا فاسو في غينيا والانفينيجر حان
الوقت لوقف هذه المهزله كما تقول اليس هذا
سببا وجيها لانهاء هذا الانقلاب
ليس سبب
السبب الوجيهي هو ان يسالوا لماذا
الانقلابات لان الانقلابات يا استاذه لا
تكون عن فراغ هكذا في سبب لهذا الانقلابات
وتلاحظ انها في الدول الفرانكفونيه فقط
التي استعملتها فرنسا في غينيا في مالي في
بوركينا فاسو وفي النيجر اذا لماذا دول
الفرنكفونيه هي التي يكثر فيها الانقلابات
فمن ذلك في خطا في كيفيه الانتخابات
فاذا ارادوا ان تنتهي الانقلابات في هذه
الدول ليس عن طريقه تدخل العسكري ولكن
لابد من اعاده التنزيم كيفيه انتخابات
واختيار الرؤساء في هذه البلدان بالمناسبه
بلداننا هذه لا يهمنا يحكمنا عسكري او
مدني
لان جل الشعب ما درسوا اصلا الذي يهمنا
الذي يوفر لنا الامن والغذاء والتعليم
والصحه سواء كان عسكريا او كان مدنيا انا
فلذلك
لابد اذا ارادوا ان ينهي مشاكل الانتخاب
انقلابات يسالوا انفسهم لماذا انقلابات
لان العسكر اللي باين عندهم رغبه في
السلطه بمعنى الكلمه لانه لا ينهبون
الاموال حتى اذا جاؤوا فقط ينظمون
دقيقه واحده اتحول بها الى
مدينه سان جندوز في الاخير فرنسا متهمه
بانها هي السبب وراءه ما يحدث في
النيجر من خلال تدخلاتها وربما تتذكر يوم
الاربعاء كان هناك
مقابله للرئيس الفرنسي لمجالات قال لولا
نحن لما وجدت اصلا هذه الدول تدخلنا في
الساحل لولا تدخلنا في الساحل ما كان هناك
لا مالي ولا بوركينا ولا النيجر ولا ربما
غيرها من الدول وجود فرنسا كلاعب اساسي في
النيجر وليس كوسيط الا يعقد الامور اكثر
نذكر ان الوضع يختلف عن 2013 حين دخلت
فرنسا لنهائي تمرد كان سوف يشعل مالي
وبالتالي يشعل الدول الاخرى ويخترق
سيادتها اذا هناك فرق كبير حين نتحدث عن
تلك المجموعات الارهابيه لانها قاتل فيما
بينها في الصحراء الكبرى
الرئيس ماكرون من هذا المنظور هو محق طبعا
تحدث هذه المقابله وربما اخطا ولكنه كان
محقا حين تحدث عن هذا الموضوع لان تلك
المعمل لم تتمكن من انهاء العمل الارهابي
نعم ادركنا الوقت نعتذر لمقاطعتك اعذرني
اعذرني على المقاطعه ايمان
بسبب انتهاء وقت البرنامج شكرا جزيلا لك
امنوا رئيس المعهد الاوروبي للدراسات
الامن والاستشراف كنت معنا من مدينه
في فرنسا في جنوب غربي فرنسا نشكر من يامي
الدكتور علي يعقوب الاكاديمي والمحلل
السياسي ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا من واشنطن
الضابط السابق في قوات النخبه الامريكيه
الى هنا تنتهي مشاهدينا هذه الحلقه من
برنامج مور الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]